[Music]
tbs if you're wondering stands for
turner broadcasting system well i was
told just a few minutes ago this is a
very nice surprise that a very special
member of the tbs family once again has
straps dropped has stopped by to say
hello please welcome the founder of tbs
mr ted turner
[Applause]
oh
well mr turner as always we are so
honored to have you here cut the
pleasantries you genderless scarecrow
i found a tbs with one purpose
to combine the artistic legacy of
florence henderson with the educational
value of off-brand professional
wrestling
and yet god continues to punish us by
letting you soil these sacred airwaves
night after night like some decaying
cockatoo okay now wait a minute i don't
think it's fair to say quiet
very sight of you makes teddy junior
wish it was mounted in the lobby of an
indian casino
of course teddy jr is your stuffed
buffalo on wheels damn it we'd have been
over this
teddy junior is an american hero and one
of wyoming's finest state senators
and he isn't stuffed your presence just
paralyzes his entire body with disgust
isn't that right teddy junior
you know i don't think i'm imagining
things i think teddy junior looks bigger
this time around well that's correct
teddy junior's been hitting the gym and
bulking up a little
he looks damn good in a bathing suit
okay so you're sure it's not because the
prop house we rent the smaller buffalo
from said it wasn't available today so
we had to rent this much larger one
shut up you infinite organ grinder
the only stiff lifeless prop is that guy
sitting next to you look at those dead
eyes
all right that's enough break it up
youtube break it up
mr turner tell us why are you here quiet
i came by the warner brothers lot to
give clint eastwood a piece of my mind
okay that's right clint eastwood has an
office here on the warner brothers lot
what's your complaint do you have a
problem with what clint eastwood said at
the republican convention last week no i
don't care about his politics i'm mad
that he stole my ass being old and crazy
is my thing
hey i was talking incoherently to empty
chairs back when clint eastwood was in
diapers which was about a year ago
that's when he started wearing the adult
i forgot sake oh mr turner shut your
pants lipped pie-hole
you want old and crazy i was married to
jane fonda
i've said global warming causes
cannibalism and i still have an aol
email address you people hear me at
a-o-l-e-mail dress
how much crazier do i have to act to get
some damn respect in this town
i'm sorry mr turner i don't think my
audience cares about any of this i don't
think that they're concerned at all your
audience you mean these these drooling
bath salt burn-ups
the only thing they have time for is
tripping on some gluten-free pot
brownies and then blowing their pell
grant money on 200 consecutive rounds of
laser tag
they're clapping but i still don't think
that's true
then it's off to dip their genitals in
pool chalk the right misleading baseball
reviews on yelp okay none of this is
making any what's that teddy junior
ah i knew he'd turn up sooner or later
conan teddy junior just informed me that
clint eastwood is at the lock gym
yelling at an empty bench press i better
get over there and spot him it is for
you people
oh god let me put this in terms you
young hippies can understand www
dot rotted hell slash screw you slash
laser tag dot htf second thank you
[Music]